[Music]
was it true that you have a book of
inspiring quotes coming out is that
right I do it tells you how to rock
climb to know it tells you how not to
rock directly what is this book of
inspiring quotes are these your quotes
or quotes that you found in life well
some of them are my own mm-hmm um I that
I've posted on Twitter that I've just
come up with in the shower and right I
know I wrote a bokken it is actually
like a morning meditation book something
that has helped me throughout the past
couple years just to say inspired and
positive which is like 365 quotes with
like a reading and then a goal for the
day and so yeah I mean I just put 365
quotes together like I said some of my
own but others like I mean everyone from
like Aristotle to Tupac so I know like
so random that I want it often that
Aristotle on Tupac really often said the
same thing but a bit of it and you also
have a new tour to announce yes I do
it's called the neon lights tour all
right
[Applause]
I gotta ask you people are you know and
I'm hoping the obsession dies down and I
think it is
I trust the disease is going away but
there's this twerking obsession that
people have and is there is there
pressure if you're a young performer
these days and you're popular out there
to twerk is there due for a feel this
pressure like ah that's what people want
I got at work or is it is your mana to
like get out there and talk baby I don't
some people look so good doing it and
well I just I just doesn't look good
doing exactly I um just think I don't
really know what it is I don't
understand is it like twitching and
working is it just dancing like why
don't we just call it dancing anymore I
don't understand dancing is it tweaking
and working like what it what is it
exactly well you're asking their worst
person in the world I'm the whitest man
in America for about I think it is
essentially booty shaking a very
particular kind of booty shake okay but
yeah different from any other dance no
other booty shaking there's been booty
shaking what's different about this Andy
I got a big booty I know how to shake it
and I just I don't know what's the
difference in doing that in twerking I
think you'll have to discover that for
yourself you're right I got present word
yeah
yeah you've got it nobody asked one of
the quotes in my book as well that's the
quote do you ship so what you do is
we're saying is you know how to shake
your booty do you shake your booty on
stage just like that just like that
Conan why am I doing this right now
because you're not really chair this is
me in a swivel chair that's the most my
booty is always in a swivel chair at all
times
that's that true it's true not sure I've
seen you standing up before you've seen
me standing up you just stood up to
greet me you are my perfect plan foiled